with local elections in the air
provincial politicking dominated today's
session including kierstama's last-ditch
pitch to voters he tried to tie
Richardson to the Fallout from his
truss's economic policies and the
consequences for homeowners
does the Prime Minister know how many
mortgage payers are paying higher rates
since the Tory party crashed the economy
last Autumn the question was how many
people are paying more on their
mortgages each month and the answer that
the Prime Minister avoided giving is 850
000 counting the cost of the Torres
economic vandalism with every mortgage
payment they make
the labor leader claimed average
first-time buyers would need to raise an
extra nine grand for their deposits
he reinforces just how out of touch he
is
nine thousand pounds nine thousand
pounds would take four years they think
it's funny you're funny the Heckler
shouted four years four years for the
average saver to save nine thousand
pounds or or to put it a different way
in terms the Prime Minister will
understand roughly the annual Bill to
heat his swimming pool
Mr sunac strategy was surprisingly
similar pouncing not just on the record
of the politician opposite but that of
his predecessors
we all know what happened last summer
they're in power there was no money left
for the country
[Applause]
speaker in London the former
conservative mayor built 60
000 affordable homes in his first five
years in office how many do the current
labor labor mayor manage half of that Mr
Speaker
and kirstama responded to the Tory jibe
about Liam Burns no money left letter
with this Jaws related pun
yeah debt doubled since 2010 growth down
tax up the economy clashed Mr Speaker
they're gonna need a bigger note
that's right
as you can see that gag received a bit
of a mixed response in the chamber which
is unac tried to slip on a jive about
Labor ditching its pledge to scrap
tuition fees in England but where the PM
struggled on that topic the smp's
Westminster leader succeeded
in 2010 David Cameron convinced Nick
Clegg to drop his Pledge on University
tuition fees does the Prime Minister
intend to take the credit for convincing
the leader of the labor party to do
likewise
I Thank The Honorable gentleman for the
question
uh I'd say it's it's hard to keep up Mr
Speaker with a list of broken promises
and when Stephen Flynn said this was the
party's Nick Clegg moment just look at
the body language on the labor front
bench elsewhere the speaker knocked over
his own glass of water with his robe
watch the reactions in this replay and
we had an almost endless stream of back
benches asking about local councils the
conservative LED solihull Council lib
Dem controlled Three Rivers district
council local conservatives tomorrow's
local elections are important not just
because it'll decide who's in charge of
things like bin collections adult social
care and Children Services but also it's
a great barometer as to the political
weather Nationwide we may get a sign
over who's likely to be crowned the next
PM but if we're honest it may all be
overshadowed by different coronation